[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to they
say never mess with a classic okay I'm
doing idle living dead
[Music]
I know it's changed so much in terms of
horror and I know it's technically a
good movie but let's face it there's
still some silly stuff in it that we can
have fun with by no means a bad movie
but still an enjoyable one to playfully
mark and that's exactly what we're gonna
do here today we're gonna poke fun of
the most famous zombie film of all time
so get ready for a healthy dose of brain
food while I get ready for a healthy
dose of hate mail this is Night of the
Living Dead the film opens with a
brother and sister visiting a cemetery
now we've still got a three-hour drive
back we're not gonna be home until after
midnight
yeah good thing you were wearing those
driving gloves buddy you leave your
goggles and scarf in the other
alternative movie you I figure we're
either gonna have to move mother out
here or move the grave into Pittsburgh
Johnny it takes you five minutes yeah
five minutes to put the wreath on the
grave and 6 hours to drive back and
forth mother wants to remember so we
trot 200 miles into the country and she
stays at home hey here's an idea why I'm
just saying you could have avoided all
this carnage if you just told your mom
you visited the grave when really you
just got drunk at a pizza place actually
if you're Freddy's is very relaxing
wonder how many times we bought the same
one
[Music]
hey come on barb church was this morning
huh
I heard asshole just remember you on the
first to die since overran all over you
you're still afraid stop it now I mean
it
they're coming for you Barbra he starts
having fun by scaring her not realizing
he's about to be intercepted by the
walking dog that coming to get you
Barbra know Josie's dad is off his meds
I wanna voice a pop a smoke fighting
animated bar animals and an alien with a
dick on his nose
crap how's about two sake dammit Janet I
love you she runs away locking herself
in the car but somebody gave this zombie
a speed and redbull cocktail because he
is fuckin wired a zombies go
[Music]
but that she remembers cars can fucking
Drive and she takes off a whole five now
dammit
this would have happened if I was
wearing my driving gloves
[Music]
and I think with government backing I
can make my silly walk very silly indeed
she finds a house to hide in where
something even scarier is inside or
maybe just the music found that scary
for some reason now that was meant to be
scary take notes music that my hitting
was weird more zombies start to approach
the house as a man shows up to try and
help her you know his head is over there
right unless you have a very slow way of
mowing the lawn
[Music]
my god back from the dead it's pee-wee
Herman's career huh I'm hiding up for
many more controversial arrest is crap
but more on the way is they like the
incredibly flammable Herman and lock
themselves inside why don't you see if
you can find some wood some boards
something there by the fireplace
something we can nail this place up look
I know you're afraid I'm afraid too but
we have to try to board the house up
together okay
I just need you to stop being the
emotional useless chick that's in every
zombie movie even if you are the first
one oh yeah that worked great thanks a
lot Bob Vila they board up the windows
and explain to each other how they got
where they are I started to drive I just
plowed right through them they didn't
move they didn't run or just stood there
staring at me just wanted to crush them
they were like people who just saw a Tom
Green movie we were riding in the
cemetery Johnny and me we came to put a
wreath on my father's grave uh yeah I
saw the first ten minutes and he said oh
it's late why did we start so late
really I think everyone the audience
know this and then this man started
walking up the road
yeah but Mayor walking up the road
Johnny kept teasing me and saying he's
coming yeah coming to get you Barbara
we're gonna trim that seam down quite a
bit
Johnny ran away you are tearing me apart
Johnny we have to go out and get Johnny
just house going hysterical pleading for
the man to go after John oh sorry you
had a fly there well to quote the giving
tree timber
he knocks her out but is fortunate to
find that the house still has a radio
hookup but somehow no phone line not
sure if the zombies cut the line or if
they just didn't pay their phone bill
but either way I guess they're really
not keying a missing game is a nanny
[Music]
it's clear that this zombie scare is
just a hoax caused by the liberal media
just simply ignore he finds himself some
firearms while Barbara continues to be
her helpful so we gotta be already food
in the radio bound to come and get us
out now I'm glad I had this talk
he takes the dead-body world be less of
an eyesore but more people come up from
downstairs I mean you didn't hear the
rap
are we supposed to know what was going
on Frank it sounded like the place was
being ripped apart how are we supposed
to know what was going on now if we
heard there was a black guy in the house
we definitely want to come up right away
back downstairs before any of those
things find out we're in here the
cellars the safest place I'm telling you
they can't get in here now you tell me
those those things can't get through
this lousy pile of wood that's as stupid
as seeing an alien race that can be
destroyed by water would be able to do
the same we have everything we need up
here we can take all that stuff
downstairs with us and you're really
crazy you know that you got a million
windows up here I told you those things
don't have any strength I smashed three
of them and pushed another one out the
door disgustin arguing with little
zombie interaction is giving me a great
idea for an AMC show huh I'll call it
bad man you booked yourself in the
cellar and those things get in the house
you've had it at least up here you have
a fighting chance oh I'm sorry
what were you saying about the cellar
something about the windows being strong
enough that God guy next time there
won't be sticking their play-doh hands
out at you
[Applause]
well enough of that nonsense back to
more cellar arguing whatever you do
don't let her make up her own damn mind
at the brightest bug in the hive so two
of them stay upstairs while the rest
hide downstairs we waited a whole ten
minutes for you down here we were kind
of hoping you were dead see when they
come begging me let them in down here
that's important what to be right
everybody else to be wrong what do you
mean by that
I what what else could you possibly mean
by that they decided to switch things up
and alternate between the upstairs and
downstairs letting everyone get more
acquainted don't be afraid of me I'm
Helen Cooper Harry's wife oh well back
to the all-important couch watching this
place is ridiculous if it's okay with
you I nominate myself the irrational
jerk of the film everybody cool with
that you cool with that I don't care
because I'm a jerk they get the TV to
work and find out more what they're
dealing with civil defense machinery has
been organized to provide rescue
stations with food shelter medical
treatment and protection by armed
National Guardsmen reports also say news
programs allow way too much Headroom in
their framing of shots experts say a
slight tilt may be in the future there's
a big key ring down there or maybe a key
to the gas company so they look to get
gas from the locked up pump nearby to
drive to one of the rescue stations our
young couple is afraid of the
consequences that could come from this
why do you have to go out there look I
know how to handle that truck and I can
handle the pump and there's no anything
about that stuff I mean I spent six
years at truck & pump University it's
complicated complicated stuff we better
get her downstairs you have to go
downstairs now just went along too
you know the area we spent 20 minutes
arguing wasn't safe so they run out to
try and get the truck more fueled up oh
yeah
I know all about handling the pump and
truck that's why I'm spilling gas all
over the fire not putting out the flames
on the wheels and blowing our asses up
to kingdom come
thank God you brought an expert like me
along
[Music]
[Applause]
but Baldy McGuirk doesn't let our hero
in resulting in him busting the door
open and giving him a beatdown
very awkward poorly choreographed
beatdown don't make me punch the outer
fabric of your necktie again well might
we the zombies enjoy their barbecue
idiots while our heroes try to figure
out what to do next ten minutes only ten
more minutes
we don't have very long to wait we're
gonna leave soon it's ten minutes to
three you are in this movie for a reason
right
the survival command center at the
Pentagon has disclosed that a ghoul can
be killed by a shot in the head or a
heavy blow to the skull of course this
footage of Texas was taken before the
zombie attack but as the nra has been
rubbing in our faces who's laughing now
we don't know how many we know when we
find them we can kill them are they
slow-moving chief yeah they're dead
they're all messed up
yes past experience has demonstrated
that the dead are in fact pretty slow
official spokesmen declined to speculate
just how long it may take to kill off
all the flesh-eaters
as long as the heavy rain we took the
power how can they do that man they're
animals
but zombies know how to use weapons come
on I don't think this movie knows the
first thing about zombies at all stupid
dumb pants tries to steal the gun but
gets it knocked out of his hands
[Music]
um my wife did it
we then begin in the always classic game
of most 60s movies who can Shatner more
spawn spawn spawn swept up a ball
Barbara finally remembers she's not the
wall and eventually tries helping out
this amounts to little though as the
wife makes a discovery downstairs
did you eat daddy again this is humor
failing for me feeding you those
dunkaroos isn't it
I guess those alien mice living inside
of her are finally getting their
comeuppance the zombies break in
grabbing Barbara led by her own brother
[Music]
actually it's good and I found you but
do you have the keys to the car
[Applause]
our main hero ironically goes down to
the cellar I dare even say everyone
would be safe if they stayed in the
cellar as the zombies realized this is a
pretty boring rave and take off but
God's middle finger isn't done yet as
our hero sees his saviors outside only
to remember the toughest part of a
zombie movie obvious commentary so what
can I say about one of the most famous
horror films of all time yeah it's got
some awkward moments but it's still a
game-changer it started a whole new
genre and still manages to leave an
uncomfortable feeling every time you see
it sure some bars are little hokey and
they're fun to giggle at but the overall
experience is still won nobody's gonna
forget anytime soon so go check it out
and see what's eating people up inside
[Music]
[Applause]
they're coming to get you Barbara